[Music]
Straight Ahead online crime daily
following fireworks in their courtroom
lawyers for the Parkland school shooter
argue that their client will not receive
a fair trial as they file a motion to
have the judge removed from the case and
argue over evidence and a California
woman is sentenced after faking her own
kidnapping and pleading guilty to
related charges will Sherry papini be
given jail time plus he said he got hit
in the side when he got hit inside with
what yes ma'am well he got shot
I don't know Atlanta police released 911
calls of a shooting that led to the
arrest of Ludacris's longtime manager
shakozulu as he's now charged with
murder then later the Pike County
Massacre is there anything remarkable or
anything that stood out to you two
things stood out to me one is that
feared as though there was forced to
entry and the second thing is there
appeared to be a transfer a small
transfer of blood testimony continues
into its second week in the trial of
George Wagner IV over his role in the
2016 murders of the Rhoden family law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to Lawton Klein daily
I'm your host Brian buckmeyer defense
attorneys for the Parkland school
shooter moved to get judge Elizabeth
schrer taken off the case Following last
week's Outburst against them in court
the new following came just days before
the defendant was set to appear in court
Monday for a hearing over a separate
matter about the admissibility of
evidence including Han Ed swastikas on a
firearm backpack and boot as well as
hate speech and racial slurs on the
defendant's social media this all stems
from the February 2017 shooting at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School in
Parkland Florida where a then 19 year
old gunman shot and killed 17 and
injured 17 others the shooter later pled
guilty to 17 Council of murder and 17
more counts of attempted murder the
question of admissibility of certain
pieces of evidence has been an issue
since the beginning of Court proceedings
the defense has fought against admitting
evidence containing Nazi symbols saying
the drawings violate the Parkland
Shooter's right to a fair trial the
motion to dismiss the judge wasn't
discussed on Monday but she denied the
request instead in a short written order
the motion came after Wednesday's
Outburst from the judge in court
I just want to say this is the most
uncalled for
unprofessional way to try a case
you you all knew about this even if you
didn't make your decision until this
morning to have 22 people plus all of
this debt and every attorney March into
court be waiting as if it's some kind of
game now I have to send them home the
state's not ready they're not going to
have a witness ready we have another day
wasted I I just I honestly I have never
experienced a level of unprofessionalism
in my career it's unbelievable
I have been practicing in this County
you know what I don't want to hear it
judge you're insulting me on the record
in front of my client and I believe that
I should be able to okay you can do that
later you can put make your records
later but you've been insulting me the
entire trial so blatantly taking your
headphones off arguing with me
um storming out coming late
intentionally if you don't like my
rulings so quite frankly this has been
long overdue
in the hearing Monday prosecutors argue
the defense opened the door for the
swastika evidence to be shown to the
jury
the defense knew what records they were
admitting they made the Strategic
decision that's a question majority
about swastikas or hate speech
they cannot now come to this court and
complain or blame the state when they
were in control of the evidence that
they were going to admit
they had the opportunity to pick and
choose their evidence the same way they
have an opportunity
to want to talk to the jury about
so now based on the fact that those
records are in evidence and that
documentation regarding this was about
and the racial slurs there any Prejudice
has now evaporated
and it's it's inevidence and they they
there were plenty of Records they didn't
have to admit those records they could
have chose bits and visas but they
didn't they put them in evidence they've
opened the door and now the state is
going to March through
joining us today is the state attorney
for Palm Beach County Dave Ehrenberg and
co-host Terry Austin did the judge's
actions cross a line in a way that she
should recuse herself
I don't think so Brian and the courts
are clear that a judge's expressions of
frustration and exasperation with
Council are not enough to bounce that
judge off of a trial and I think what's
really going on here is that the defense
Council want to preserve this issue for
appeal they're going to go after the
judge on appeal in hopes of overturning
any death penalty conviction here and so
that's what they're doing because they
know that she's not going to recuse
herself if she did that would cause such
a huge delay in this trial they have to
do the whole thing all over again and
should essentially have to admit that
she was biased so that's not going to
happen this is an appellate move and
also one more thing Brian they may be
playing for the next call that's what
you do in a sports game you know you
yelled the referees not to get the last
call reverse you're hoping to change the
call that comes next so I don't think
this is going to have any immediate
impact on the case yeah I'll see what
that next call is and see if that gamble
works out for them Terry should the
racial slurs and swastikas come in
especially where he uses the n-word but
doesn't Target any people of color or
black or African-American oh I
definitely think those swastikas should
come in it has been already opened as
far as the prosecution said the defense
opened that door and they're marching
right in it's relevant it demonstrates
motive and also it's more probative than
prejudicial remember the defense has
raised this over and over and the judge
has said I will Reserve I will wait to
see what happens I will wait to see what
evidence comes in and I think the
defense thinks it's highly prejudicial
but the judge actually said why is this
more prejudicial than other comments
other pejorative comments and so I think
she's right it should all come in yeah
today's point this could be the next
ruling by the by the referee and see how
they'll decide on this one because B
major for both sides well in California
testimony resumes but gets a late start
Monday in the 1996 case of The
Disappearance of Kristen smart as Father
and Son Paul and Ruben Flores send trial
for her murder 26 years later smart was
a Cal Poly a student who went missing
after a party in may of 1996 but the
case went cold for two decades with very
few leads Paul and Ruben Flores were
long suspected in her disappearance and
were arrested just last year Witnesses
say Paul was the last person seen with
smart he is charged with her murder his
father Reuben is charged with accessory
after the fact prosecutors say he helped
hide the body and is accused of burying
her in his backyard and later moving her
remains Smart's body has never been
found on the stand Monday was a forensic
DNA analyst an expert in bodily fluids
who's worked on several cold cases while
explaining her background for the jury
she testified she's handled hundreds of
cases over the last 20 years testimony
expected to last through at least
October and despite several delays
including four days off last week the
judge says they're right on schedule
and in Maryland a man found guilty of
murder 22 years ago has his conviction
overturned this comes after a joint
request from the defense and prosecutors
anans case Rose to Fame in 2014 when the
podcast serial broke listening records
the investigative series cast doubt on
his 2000 conviction for the 1999 murder
of his high school girlfriend 18 year
old hey Ming Lee he has been behind bars
since his 1999 arrest and since then
Syed has maintained his innocence in the
latest following prosecutors called for
said to be freed over new information
about two alternate suspects the two
were known to investigators but were not
properly ruled out or disclosed to the
defense and they had serious charges on
their criminal records including serial
rape and sexual assault on Monday the
judge overturned syad's conviction and
released him under home detention the
judge also ordered a new trial
still had our long crime daily
California woman Sherry papini is
sentenced in federal court after
pleading guilty to charges related to a
2016 kidnapping hoax but first Atlanta
music executive and long-time manager of
hip-hop artist Ludacris Shaka Zulu is
facing murder charges after a shooting
earlier this year resulted in a man's
death
[Music]
welcome back California mother of two
Sherry papini is sentenced in federal
court Monday following a kidnapping hoax
which garnered national attention back
in April papini pled guilty to two
counts of mail fraud and lying to an
officer after November 2016 incident
when papini allegedly went missing 22
days later she was found on an
interstate about 150 miles south of
where she was reported missing papini
claimed two Hispanic women in a dark SUV
abducted and tortured her but her
ex-boyfriend told investigators papini
actually stayed with him during the time
she was missing and that she inflicted
injuries including branding to herself
papini was married with two children at
the time according to court document
papini will pay more than three hundred
thousand dollars in restitution to the
agencies involved in her search
prosecutors recommended eight months
behind bars on Monday she was sentenced
to 18 months in jail followed by three
years of supervised release
Terry between the jail time the the
supervision and restitution do you think
this is the right punishment and that it
will deter others from doing the same
it's absolutely the right punishment and
hopefully it will deter others from
doing something similar listen the
prosecutors as you mentioned they only
asked for eight months and defense asked
for one you normally see that but here
the judge sentenced her to 18 months in
prison I definitely think they're trying
to send a message it's more than twice
as much as the prosecution requested and
then 36 months of survive you know
supervised release that's a long time so
I think it may seem unusually harsh and
it is but these are serious crimes you
lied to the FBI and you commit male
fraud you mislead the public you spend a
lot of money and I think the restitution
part of this is important too because it
shows look you might waste our time and
our money but you're going to pay back
yeah now Dave the prosecution pushed
back on defense's request for just one
month and in jail arguing the public
harm papini created what harm do you see
that she created if any
a lot and Terry's right I agree with the
sentence and there's a number of
different types of harms first she
accused two Hispanic women of abducting
her so you have that thrown out into the
universe the racism there and that's
pretty awful but also all the hours of
legwork that law enforcement spent on
this case that were diverted from other
cases and so you want to try to send a
message that we should never have uh
misused the system and people should
never do what she did also you know when
she was given a chance to cop to this
when the investigators came to her and
said hey your ex-boyfriend is saying
this uh your boyfriend is saying this
and you want to admit to it now well she
denied it again so the LIE continued way
past the time it should have ended
exactly we'll see well that seems to be
the end of The papini Saga 18 months in
jail restitution and three years of
supervised release thank you both coming
up on lawn crime daily a high profile
Atlantic Music executive is facing
murder charges after Shaka Zulu was
involved in a shooting at a restaurant
which left three people shot and one man
killed plus testimony from law
enforcement agents describes processing
the many crime scenes in the trial of
Pike County Massacre defendant George
Wagner IV
[Music]
welcome back we head to Georgia as music
executive and long time manager of
hip-hop artist Ludacris Shaka Zulu is
charged with murder over a shooting in
an Atlanta strip mall parking lot
earlier this year Mozilla was one of
three men shot in the June 26 shooting
and nearly died himself according to his
attorneys officers arrived at the scene
around 11 30 that night to find the
three men with gunshot wounds artez
Benton died of his injuries after being
taken to the hospital investigators
later identified Zulu as a suspect
charging him with murder aggravated
assault possession of a firearm during a
crime and simple battery Zulu turned
himself into authorities and was
released the same day after posting a
two hundred thousand dollar Bond his
attorneys say he fired his weapon in
self-defense after being attacked by at
least four men they say he was shot in
the back and nearly lost his life and
that he is still recovering from his
injuries Zulu has been rep presenting
ludicrous since the 1990s and has been
more recently served as head of artists
and talent for the music streaming
service Spotify officials only recently
released three 911 calls from the night
of the shooting
right now at apartment 4B I have can I
have the address
man I don't I don't know the address on
other restaurants
I need you to tell me where you are
first I'm going to get all the
information
I'm at a restaurant it's called
apartment 4B it got hit in the side
can you hear me
look at me look at me open your eyes
he's responding appropriately
real calm
Terry 200 000 Bond on a murder sounds
pretty low could that be an indication
of the prosecution's case isn't that
strong you know what Brian I agreed is
relatively low but based on the reports
that we've heard so far I think the case
against him does not sound overwhelming
first of all he was shot in the back it
doesn't necessarily mean he wasn't the
aggressor but it does indicate to me
that he was caught off guard and he is
claiming self-defense he's saying that
these four men came up upon him and he
said he returned the fire or at least
the reports are to defend his life he
had a weapon but it was a licensed
weaponed and he turned himself in and
he's a long time executive I think for
all of those reasons the bail was set at
a relatively low amount because he can
be trusted he'll come back to court and
he himself almost died so for for those
reasons I do think it made sense yeah I
think the licensed weapon really saved
him in that in that situation Dave three
men found that a scene all shot one dies
you're the state attorney in Palm Beach
how does a prosecutor figure out who to
charge oh it's a tough one you got to
talk to Witnesses you got to get the
surveillance video and you got to make
the decision as to who was the initial
aggressor and who uses disproportionate
Force I agree with Terry it's gonna be a
tough one because of his lack of
criminal record his uh position as an
executive the fact that he was shot in
the back and the fact that he turned
himself in and so you can tell that the
prosecution doesn't think it's that
strong of a case already because of the
low Bond yeah just to give an example
when I'm practicing in Brooklyn you can
see a quarter million dollar bond for an
attempted murder so when I see 200 000
on a murder that to me kind of raises my
public defender's ears to say maybe the
defense has something here but of course
we'll keep eyes on this case as it
continues when we come back Ohio's Pike
County Massacre trial stretches into a
second week as George Wagner IV is tried
for murder and jurors hear a testimony
from those who process one of the many
crime scenes
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
testimony in the Pike County Massacre
stretches into its second week as George
Wagner the fourth stands trial for his
role in the 2016 shooting deaths of
eight members of the rodent and Gilly
families Wagner along with his brother
Jake and their parents Billy and Angela
were all charged for their involvement
in the shooting deaths of the rodent and
Gilly families in April of 2016. the
murders allegedly came amid an ugly
custody dispute involving a young child
Jake shared with Hannah Rhoden the
victims were found shot to death in
their homes most were shot as they slept
Jake previously pled guilty to the
murders and will spend the rest of his
life in prison he's agreed to testify
against his brother and father Angela
has also pled guilty and is expected to
testify at Georgia's trial Georgia's
defense argue he's not guilty because he
didn't actually pull the trigger on
Monday morning testimony continued from
Bureau of criminal investigation agent
Shane hansha he tested by that none of
the evidence collected at the crime
scene where Chris and Gary rhoden's
bodies were found contained DNA linked
to any of the defendants in this case he
told the jury however there were signs
of force entry at a structure on the
same property
at some point you said you had noticed
security cameras on this building when
you were up in that area did you notice
a security camera in that vicinity yes
exhibit a114 you can see the top portion
of the door and above that is a camera
my own Adair we thought it appeared as
though it were pointing toward the
residents we attempted to look for any
kind of re recording device that would
have maybe documented what happened or
given us some idea I will try seeing
wires back they LED inside
and uh
we found nothing no recording device
before going into that that room did you
examine that door a little more further
for other evidence or possibility of
evidence yes and as you looked at that
door was there anything remarkable or
anything that stood out to you two
things stood out to me one is it
appeared as though there was fourth
century
which would be consistent with the door
handle lying on the the upper surface of
the porch and the second thing is there
appeared to be a transfer a small
transfer of Blood on the exterior face
of that door
all right so Dave we heard it just there
signs of force entry but that happened
away from where the bodies were found so
does that create any kind of Reasonable
Doubt as to who actually committed these
murders
perhaps but there are other counts where
you don't have to actually show this guy
as the direct murderer to get him a
serious sentence and also the biggest
evidence for me is that his own mother
and brother are testifying against him
I've never heard of someone's mother
testifying against them that should be
enough this is a horrific tragedy that
happened and I think the fact that all
these other people have been convicted
for the same crime means this guy's
going down too just a question of which
of the serious crimes he will be guilty
of yeah we often call something like
this a long plea negotiation because
eventually something he might be found
guilty of something
BCI agent handshaw testified and the
party stipulated that there was no DNA
for George Jake Angela or even Billy
Wagner at the scene where what where uh
Kristen and Gary wrote and were found
what could that mean
you know that scene one didn't find any
DNA from any of the Wagners and at first
you might think and that's a problem as
far as the prosecution is concerned but
I don't think it is I think the
prosecution was very good when they
questioned BCI agent Henshaw because he
made clear that if you wore gloves then
there would be no DNA transfer he didn't
go so far as to say well can we say that
the Wagners were wearing gloves but he
made it clear that that is a possibility
and if in fact they were wearing gloves
what that means is this was cold it was
calculated it was premeditated and Dave
is exactly right your mother is
testifying against you that's plenty of
evidence for this jury to say the
Wagners were there at that scene whether
or not there was DNA they were very
careful to make sure there was no DNA
still guilty all right don't commit
crimes be kind to your mother you never
know what she'll testify to you well
thank you both and thank you for joining
us is here on Law and crime daily we'll
see you next time as we discuss Justice
in America
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]